PROFESSOR: So now we've
included all the key physics
in our model--
sedimentation, deactivation of
virus, filtration of the air,
ventilation flows.
And now, we have to include
one last piece of information,
which is that all
of those quantities,
or many of them that
we've discussed,
have a dependence on the
size of the droplets.
And the size of the droplets
and number of the droplets
is a strong function of
the type of respiration
which is being performed
by the infected person who
is spewing out or
emitting these droplets,
and also the respiration of
the susceptible person who's
breathing those droplets in.
So here is a sketch of what
droplet distributions look
like that have been
measured for different kinds
of expiratory activities.
So this is shown kind
of on a log scale,
at least what I'm
attempting to sketch.
So the dotted line
here, roughly speaking,
is separating the
aerosol droplets,
which are less than
several microns in radius
and the large droplets,
which are bigger than that.
And what you can see here
is that as you change
from resting breathing,
which is let's
say through the nose or
even resting breathing
through the mouth, this
distribution starts to go up.
When you start speaking,
there's a significant increase
in the emissions.
Presumably because there is
a fragmentation and breakup
of mucus which is surrounding
the vocal cords in the pharynx.
Which leads to significant
aerosol emissions, which do not
evaporate and do not
follow the Wells curve,
but actually survive.
And then that becomes
much more extreme
as we get towards singing and
any prolonged vocalizations.
In fact, also, this
size here depends
on the volume of speaking.
So this is loud speaking,
and somewhere below here
is whispering.
So basically, the
amount that you release
is a strong function of
the volume of speech.
And whether you're
vocalizing or not
makes a big difference, where
vocalization leads to many more
droplets being formed
that are aerosols
that remain in the air.
And singing is actually probably
almost as bad as you can get,
in terms of spewing
out droplets.
What's interesting is that
all these distributions have
a peak or the most
probable value
is actually less than a micron.
So it's around
maybe half a micron
in diameter, which is even
a quarter micron in radius.
But it can vary.
So it's somewhere
in the range of,
let's just say 0.3 to
one micron is somewhere
where you'll find the peak
of these distributions.
And then they drop off, but in
such a way that they're not--
they're dropping off
fairly quickly in number,
but since the larger droplets
carry more volume, like R
cubed, it turns out they're
not decaying quite so quickly
as a function of volume.
But still, they are
decaying and the peak
is in the aerosol range.
So clearly, there is a strong
size dependence there which
you must take into account.
But that's not it.
We've already talked about
other quantities which
also strong size dependence.
So we've talked
about infectivity.
If we think about
a water droplet,
I was calculating the
time for the virion
to get out of the water
droplet by diffusion.
And we saw that even up to 10
micron-type sizes, the virion
can still escape.
On the other hand,
if it's in mucus,
as the droplets that are emitted
from-- especially vocalization
patterns-- then you'll
find that, as we've already
calculated, that cutoff
where you start to not
have time for the
virus to get out
might be on the
order of microns.
And so we're
certainly going to see
that the aerosols
are infectious,
and that has been
shown experimentally.
But we may not find that they're
as infectious in the larger
drop form.
So that's something
we could also
take into account in the model.
And then of course
masks and air filters
have a strong
dependence on size,
and that's included
in their ratings.
So for example, when
we go from an N95 mask
to various forms of
cloth face covering,
there's a lot of experimental
data showing the transmission
of those different droplet sizes
through different materials.
And in addition to the material,
there's also the fit factor.
So you can have a
really great material.
If you measure it, it's 99%
removing the aerosol droplets.
But then you put on
your face and you've
got a big gap over
your nose or you let
it sink down below your nose.
And suddenly, you're
letting a lot out as well.
So the fit of the mask
is also very important,
and somehow ends up being
included in this quantity.
But clearly, there's a
strong size dependence.
Although, I would point
out, both these quantities
are not varying too much
over the aerosol range.
So if we're focusing
on aerosols,
then the variation isn't as much
as you might think, actually.
So what happens
with the filters is
when you get to bigger
than 10 microns,
like 10 millimeter
scale, then there's
a physical blocking
of those droplets
and they get condensed
and collected
on the fibers of the material.
And so there's almost
100% of filtration
at the scale of millimeters.
So when you have a
large cough or sneeze,
if you are wearing a mask--
even a fairly poor mask-- a lot
of it gets filtered.
Yes, some drops do get through
and that's been observed,
but it's very significantly
filtered at the high sizes.
On the other hand, when you
get down to the aerosols,
then the masks may not
be filtering so strongly.
And the same thing
with the filters.
So the HEPA filter
is intended to remove
the aerosol droplets, even
those which are below a micron.
But the various MERV
ratings of filters
are not really going after the
aerosols as much, but still
have a significant removal.
Maybe in the order
of tens of a percent,
or maybe up to even 90%,
depending on the rating.
So the point is, all these
quantities are size dependent.
So we have to go back and
revisit our model including
that size dependence.
OK, so it just makes things a
little bit more complicated,
but not too much.
So let's go back yet
again to our mass balance,
but now we're going to do it
in a radius resolved fashion.
And so for this, I'm
in need a C of R and t,
and I'm going to use the same
notation, C, even though I've
just changed the meaning
here by including the R.
And this is going to be a
radius resolved concentration
of virions.
So that means it's
a number of virions
per air volume per radius, OK?
And so, now when we write
the mass balance, instead of
a dC dt with an
order derivative,
it's actually a
partial derivative.
Because C is now a
function of R and t.
So I have a partial
dC dt, and then
if I divide through by
volume on the other side,
I have a P which
now depends on R.
So the production
rate of droplets
is certainly very
strongly size-dependent,
and then all these other
factors may come in as well.
Divided by volume.
And then, we have a lambda
C, which now depends
on R times concentration.
So this is now what happens
to our mass balance.
And this lambda C of R--
what does that look like?
Well, it's lambda
a times one plus--
and then we have the
sedimentation effect.
And I'm going to write
this as R over RC squared.
Because we know the
sedimentation of velocity
scales like R squared.
I'll come back to
this in just a moment.
This is sedimentation.
That's the tricky part.
It is strongly size-dependent.
Plus lambda v and plus Pf
lambda f, which of course,
depends on R as well.
Lambda v in principle
could depend on R,
although we haven't
really considered that.
We've been thinking of more just
spontaneous or maybe chemical
disinfectants.
In the case of
chemical disinfectants,
maybe that's size-dependent too
because whether the virion is
attacked by a chemical depends
on how big the droplet is.
So in principle, this could
also be size-dependent.
So basically, everything
is size-dependent.
Except for lambda a as the
airflow, air changed rate.
And that, of course,
does not depend on size.
Now, what have I
done here in this RC?
So I've written here that
if I write lambda s of R
is the sedimentation
rate, that's
vs of R divided by the height.
So basically, that's
what we talked about
before as the rate at which
particles are sedimenting
onto the horizontal surfaces.
Where, remember H is v over a.
And then what I've
done here-- notice,
so what was supposed to
be here is lambda s of R,
but then I factored
out lambda a.
So what this term is here is
lambdas s of R over lambda a.
That is by definition--
so that's the same
as vs of R over va,
were va is the air velocity.
So that's Q, the air flow
rate, the outdoor air flow
rate divided by a.
And then we're writing
that as R over RC
squared because we know that
vs scales like R squared.
So when I factor this out,
I can define a quantity RC.
And what does that
RC turn out to be?
That is-- basically,
you can actually just
see by working it through
this form formula.
Actually, I'll just leave it
here as a definition basically.
Now, then we can
also now say what
happens to these kinds
of droplet distributions.
So this is kind of
the important thing,
is that lambda C
is something which
has some R dependence from
filtration, as we're sketching
here, but it has
also very strong R
dependence from sedimentation.
So we don't show it here, but
the sedimentation velocity kind
of increases like R squared.
So that's a pretty
big dependence.
And so what that
means is that if I
take some of these initial
droplet distributions
that are coming
from breathing-- so
imagine this is kind of
the drop of distribution
soon after the aerosols
leave the mouth,
after the initial
evaporation has taken place,
but the Wells curve has
been disrupted by the fact
that there's mucus with lots of
solute and charged molecules.
And so the droplets have reached
an equilibrium distribution
that looks something
like is shown here.
If I then ask myself what
happens at a later time,
how does that build up?
So let's say one person in
the room who is-- basically
one of these curves
is describing
the distribution of
droplets that they
are emitting from breathing.
So let's ask ourselves what
happens to the concentration
profile in those cases.
So there is an RC here
and R. And basically
as you can see, when
R is less than RC,
then the sedimentation
term is small.
And essentially
it's just lambda a.
So that means that the removal
of the infectious particles
is dominated by ventilation,
which is not size dependent.
So when you're
less than RC, which
is another way of defining
the aerosol range,
that is where you don't have
a strong size dependence.
But when you're in the large
drop category, of course
those drops are sedimenting.
And in fact, this term
can be very large.
If we go out to 10 microns
or even up to a millimeter,
the sedimentation rate
is incredibly fast.
And those droplets are
very quickly removed
and do not end up
swirling around the room,
as we've been describing.
So let's imagine we take-- let's
say it's somebody speaking.
And let's say that, just
for illustration purposes,
let's say it initially
looks like this.
So this is kind of the
initial profile that's
in the room in early times.
Now at first, until we get to
a time inverse of lambda C,
that's the concentration
or relaxation time.
Over that time scale,
the concentration
is going to be building.
But it's building the
fastest in the aerosol range
because those guys
are not being removed.
These guys, though,
are being removed.
So instead of
increasing, it doesn't
increase that much because
they're also being removed.
So what happens at a later
time is that this goes up,
but not so much over there.
And it gets more and more
peaked in the aerosol range
because here you have basically
fast removal of large drops.
But here, you have slow
buildup of aerosols.
So if you wait for a timescale--
the time it takes here,
time is basically
lambda C inverse.
So we call that tC
or tau C, that's
the timescale for buildup.
That's the inverse of this.
That's how long it takes to
essentially reach steady state.
And where you really get
the biggest increase is
among the aerosol,
because over here
you're basically losing them.
Now, there are
filtration effects too,
and there's also
the infectivity.
So there are other
competing size dependencies
that might actually emphasize
the large scale here,
so I want to make sure
we're clear about that.
But these size
dependencies are bounded.
For example, the mass
filtration is sort of
bounded by one, right?
But R squared just keeps going.
So if you go to larger
and larger particles,
they sediment faster
and faster and faster.
OK.
And so it really is true--
I didn't draw this
very well, but if you
get to like large
sizes on the order of,
let's say millimeters,
those droplets really
never build up in
the air because they
sediment almost immediately.
When you cough or sneeze,
the largest droplets fall
and it happens very quickly.
It might happen in a
few seconds or a minute.
And we're talking
about timescales here
that are on the order
of the air change
rate, which might be
on the order of hours
or tens of minutes.
So basically, this
size-dependent relaxation
tends to kind of sharpen
distribution right
into the aerosol range.
Which is, again,
why we're talking
about indoor airborne
transmission being dominated
by these aerosols
that are swirling
around the well-mixed room.
And that's very different
from transmission
through coughs or sneezes
of large droplets, which
are only very briefly present
and then they sediment out.
So if you're not standing
in the way of that cough,
or if the cough is blocked
by a mask or a shield,
then you really don't have to
worry as much about that form
of transmission.
But as shown here,
you do have to worry
about the aerosols which
are building up in the air
and are very strongly related
to all these different factors
that we've been talking about.
And in fact, maybe I
should also sketch--
just to help understand
this picture,
maybe I should draw lambda
C as a function of R.
So where this RC is-- again, I
was kind of saying it in words,
but it's dividing a situation
when you're less than RC,
where basically these
quantities aren't varying
too much, to the
situation above where
it's growing like R squared.
So basically a much
faster relaxation, again,
separating aerosols
from large drops.
So if we substitute
the Stokes velocity
that we've been talking about
earlier into this formula here,
we can actually
derive what RC is.
And it comes out to
be the square root
because it is defined with RC
squared of nine halves, that's
from the Stokes formula.
We have lambda a,
the air change rate;
the effective height of
the room or ceiling height;
the viscosity of air;
and the denominator
is two times the density
of the liquid and gravity.
And this number it
turns out is also
on the order of a few microns.
So it does depend
on what lambda a is,
but lambda a on the order of
tens of minutes to hours, this
is a kind of range.
It can be smaller.
It can be bigger.
In fact, it could be--
maybe it could even be like
0.5 microns up to 5 microns.
0.5 to 5 microns is
probably more accurate.
But basically, it's
sitting there right about--
as I was trying to sketch here--
in the barrier between aerosols
and non aerosols.
And also below RC
is actually where
the peak of the distributions
is from typical expiratory
activities.
And so the point is that
those are not being affected
very much by sedimentation.
Now the last thing
I'll mention is that
as soon as we have these kind of
size-dependent properties, what
happens to our calculation
of transmission?
I'll just put the mathematical
formula on the board
here without really
dwelling on it.
But the way you
can plot what I've
sketched down here for an
actual distribution shown here
would be to substitute it into
the formulas we had before.
So for example, what is the
time-dependent transmission
rate?
Well remember, that's
Qb times the integral
over all the sizes now of all
the size-dependent qualities.
So it's PM of R, C of R and
t, and C I of R dR, where
CI is the infectivity.
So basically, as you solve
this [INAUDIBLE] equation here,
there's sort of change of
the concentration field,
as I've sketched.
You have to then
integrate these curves
against these other factors--
the mass factor and the
infectivity factor--
in order to figure
out the transmission
rate at that moment
through the well-mixed air.
And if we solve
this equation here,
we can actually substitute
back in and get our formula
for beta, which is that beta
of t is Qb squared over v.
So here I'm substituting P
of R. So remember before,
P was basically nd times
C times the infectivity.
So that was basically the
production rate of virions
and we've already
seen that before.
And so when I kind of substitute
the solution that we've already
derived, but just
keeping track of the fact
that these quantities
are all radius-dependent
and appear under
the integral, we
are left with the
integral from zero
to infinity of Pn of R
squared Cv CI of R. Cv
is the concentration of virions
per liquid volume or mucous
volume in the droplet.
CI of R is the infectivity.
And let's see, then we have
also an nd of R vd of R,
where vd of R is
the droplet size.
All divided by lambda C of
R, which is all this stuff.
And this integrand is multiplied
by the exponential relaxation,
one minus e to the
lambda C of Rt dR.
So this is your
general formula for
the time-dependent transmission
rate in a room where
you can select an actual
distribution that corresponds
to the infected persons
breathing activity
and tells you the kinds
of aerosol droplets
that they are emitting,
and then you basically
have all these other
parameters to do
with filtration and airflow and
ventilation, viral deactivation
and sedimentation.
And you finally have
to do this integral
and you end up with
the transmission rate.